yes I'm in the bathroom no follow-up
questions what you're about to see is a
video for the YouTube dear--my campaign
this is the only paper of substance I
had to write the son and I think he gets
the point across this is a movement
YouTube starting to empower and inspire
young women and we were asked to make a
video what advice would I give to my
teenage self here we go if I could go
back in time and talk to my younger self
I think the advice I would give my
younger self is don't be afraid of being
afraid I was a very fear-based young
person afraid of socialising afraid of
ever showing insecurities afraid of
really putting myself out there anyway
but I really really really wanted to put
myself out there improv comedy has a
philosophy follow your fear and only now
as an adult do I understand that and
believe it's a great philosophy things
that you are afraid of ID rather than
like sharks and spiders because you
don't you don't need to really follow
them also I'm a bad swimmers to
following a shark it's just not gonna
work out for me but things like putting
yourself out there asking someone out on
a date or just the simplicity of having
a conversation with a stranger can be
really terrifying but if you follow your
fear and you say yes to a situation or
an opportunity or a person sometimes you
will find yourself in a really great
place with really great people and
really great opportunities that you
could have never seen for yourself
before so follow your fear also don't
forget to laugh the same way people say
oh if you get in situations where
there's high anxiety or whatever don't
forget to breathe
don't forget to laugh there's no greater
feeling than laughing genuinely when the
feeling of laughter just happens upon
you because of a situation or something
said or something you've seen or
whatever it is it is the greatest
feeling in the world so let yourself
would be open to how fun and um life can
be celebrate the silly celebrate the
stupid we're all gonna die someday so
see on the other side now I encourage
all of you to tell me your dear me
stories and if you are 30
years old what would you tell your
six-year-old self
sure why not let me know with the
hashtag dear me you guys are all really
great or at least a solid medium